I gotta say this is exciting I am here
in a Warner Brothers soundstage and I'm
standing with the beautiful gal gadot
Wonder Woman hi nice to see you
when I called and said would you meet me
in a warehouse I was shocked that you
said yes
very excited about your upcoming film
thank you so much and the big question I
had was how did this woman transform
herself into Wonder Woman
six months prior to the shoots I had to
do a lot of gym work and and martial
arts so you said it took you roughly six
months to become Wonder Woman I don't
want this to be taken as an insult
but I've got about 35 minutes that is
all the time I need to become Wonder
Woman you know I can fight you were
trained in the Israeli army yeah that's
probably where it all began I was a girl
scout for three months now the first
thing I'm gonna do to prepare is remove
this jacket you ready what you're about
to see the honestly my body assess it
and don't be afraid to be mean tell me
what you see what are the strengths
where the weaknesses very weak legs man
who's bigger that's fine we can worth
anything you're saying that I am NOT
built like a man I think you'll be
shocked by what this can do okay
especially needs so you know let's meet
your trainer let's bring them in rude
ass so this is your trainer and your
name is Hoda Luda yes and you are from
where
Czech Republic Czech Republic legs she
said they're weak you assess them
probably shocked at what I can do there
long
you see what I would use is my long
waist
oh you have like that could stop my legs
I can do this as long as you can do it I
can do it all day long some kicks some
kicks yeah yeah
huh and bring you back okay
that's the kid that's it that's it so
bend the knee then kick that's it you're
gonna lean on you either supports Remini
and then kick this is right this is what
they teach you in the Israeli army this
is the first day isn't case war breaks
out that's how we do it in Boston all I
say okay Luda what's next
sword now you come in how do I defend
against that you block me Ruda how do I
block it no you can block antenna and
the same oh look at your sword yes let's
two three okay one two three amazing so
bad look how I look to the camera as if
they say then while I'm busy doing that
Ruda we've been doing this a very short
time would you say that already I'm
making incredible progress now I'm
really getting the wonder you know I
feel I feel powerful but also pretty at
the same time do I don't ever use these
yeah to block and deflect okay things
you can block bullets with those right
the thing was exactly baby they can put
in in post right now they're gonna put
in bullets
[Music]
[Applause]
okay my Dawson training is complete and
now we will see that the man is superior
to the woman I'll be honest with you I'm
not feeling great about in this segment
you know you did where you say oh but
you look great know what I'd like to do
if you have just a minute I'd like to
just step off camera for a second and
come back in a way that I think will
impress you
their legs it's so much bigger now
that's the first thing that is a thicker
hair is real that's the realest part in
the next Wonder Woman movie do you think
there would be a possibility that I
could be on camera as a possible love
interest for Wonder Woman we can add
anything yes okay we can just add you
saying yes
okay so admin thing yes I could be on
camera as a possible love interest for
Wonder Woman yes it's really really
really it's just different the one thing
we have not mastered is horse riding one
woman is a great rider is insane we
couldn't get a horse none of the Warner
Brothers lot but we do have the next
best thing this is the best we can do
this makes it look like sitting on a
mechanical bull arouses me okay is this
thing I think it's dying I mean this
feels like it just has hepatitis well
Wonder Woman comes out June 2nd the
movies pretty much what you're seeing
right now of that ride the Wonder Woman
maybe I'm coming to rescue you
I think you're very beautiful
and I don't think you're seeing it my
best you know you're attracted to me
tell you how it be we're both married go
get up
[Applause]
you